die stadt hamm hat bundesweit die
höchsten coroner neuinfektion und die
werte klettern immer weiter hoch am
mittwoch wurden 94,9 neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohner verzeichnet als
auslöser der korona infektionswelle in
hamm gilt eine große hochzeit und damit
verbundene feste den haben dortmund und
wer stattgefunden haben
insgesamt sollen mindestens 300 neun
teilnehmer aus haben dabei gewesen sein
sie alle müssen jetzt also in quarantäne
und getestet werden
bei meinem kollegen andreas wegener ist
jetzt der oberbürgermeister der stadt
hallo nele ja innerhalb weniger tage wie
du es gerade gesagt es hat es meine
heimatstadt haben geschafft traurige
berühmtheit eben dadurch zu erlangen
dass sie die zweite welle der korona
neuinfektionen hart getroffen hat
hintergrund ist eben diese türkische
hochzeit ich habe ihnen mit dem
veranstalter sprechen können
bei dem wohl der erste dieser drei
abende stattgefunden hat das war ein
sogenannter hannah abend wo sich die
frauen vor der hochzeit treffen und
zusammen feiern 46 frauen haben in den
veranstaltungssaal zusammen gefeiert und
zwei so stellte sich nachher heraus
hatten corona wang corona positiv die
der veranstalter legt wert auf die
feststellung dass er sofort alle
meldewege eingehalten hat das
ordnungsamt informiert hat die listen
mit den teilnehmern zur verfügung
gestellt hat dennoch konnte auch zu dem
zeitpunkt schon nicht mehr verhindert
werden dass sich viele leute infiziert
haben
und letztlich geht man im moment davon
aus dass mindestens 100 teilnehmer
dieser türkischen hochzeit infiziert
sind und das führte dazu dass eben in
hamm die zahl der neuinfektionen so
explodiert ist bei mir steht jetzt der
oberbürgermeister der stadt haben was
tun sie damit die situation jetzt wieder
eingedämmt wird
also wir haben jetzt verschiedene
maßnahmen ergriffen zum beispiel die
masten pflichtschulen
wir haben all das versammlungsverbot für
mehr als fünf teilnehmer bzw
zwei familienverbände in etwa so wie es
wird wie wir es bereits zu beginn der
korona krise hatten wir haben
insbesondere für diese und ähnliche
veranstaltungen eine allgemeinverfügung
erlassen
das ab 25 personen bis 50 eine
meldepflicht besteht zwischen 50 und 100
50 personen auch das
genehmigungspflichtig ist dass uns das
vorgelegt wurde weil im zuge dieser
ermittlungen haben wir einfach
festgestellt wir können natürlich
gewohnt richtlinien nur kontrollieren
wenn wir auch wissen dass es die
veranstaltung überhaupt gibt
denn die korona verordnung des landes
nordrhein westfalen die wir haben sie im
grunde bis 150 keine weiteren
einschränkungen vor die sollen sich an
die korona regeln natürlich halten aber
es gibt wieder eine melde dich noch der
genehmigung
jetzt hat es ja auch dazu geführt dass
in haben schüler zum beispiel wieder im
unterricht masken tragen müssen wenn die
abstände von 1 meter 50 nicht
eingehalten werden können wann werden
denn diese beschränkungen zurückgefahren
kann sie dazu schon das sagen so bald
wie möglich so bald wie möglich heisst
da müssen wir deutlich unter 50 unter
dem lkw faktor 50 wieder sein
je nach dem verlauf der pandemie könnte
das ende nächster woche schon der fall
sein
aber wie gesagt ich bin kein prophet ich
weiß nicht ob noch eine zweite oder
dritte welle im rahmen dieser ansteckung
kommt also uns hat es praktisch
überrollt ich bin auch nach wie vor ein
bisschen wütend weil die frage ob die
alle ob die zahlen eingehalten worden
sind ist ja das eine aber das einhalten
von abständen ist das andere und die
abstände sind garantiert bei männer fest
nicht eingehalten worden
also das muss man einfach auch der weit
halber sagen die große feier hat
allerdings auch in dortmund
stattgefunden
wir überlegen jetzt auch rechtliche
schritte wir haben allerdings auch
regelungen gefunden glaube ich
jedenfalls die das leben in der stadt
aufrechterhalten ich weiß aus der korona
pandemie heraus
das im grunde genommen es keinen sinn
macht jetzt zum beispiel eine sporthalle
zu schließen mir ist jetzt kein einziger
fall bekannt wo aus einer sporthalle
heraus jedenfalls bei uns in der stadt
eine infektion herauskam
wir haben es also sehr differenziert
gemacht ich möchte auf jeden fall ein
locker und vermeiden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren